dard alias san antonio est publié aux
éditions du fleuve noir votre qui vient
conter 105e je précise qu'à pas chez moi
en fait jamais fait 105e san antonio ce
qui fait beaucoup 4 pas mais c'est pas
fini
mais si vous marquez déjà des signes de
lassitude les non pas de s'aimer c'est
la cabane pas lui à peu près la moitié
d'après ses estimations du produit les
parents et ça fait des années que ça
dure
le le dernier s'intitule vient avec ton
cierges
oui c'est un san antonio latino
américains oui je le balade beaucoup oui
regret de vous savez de ma fantaisie je
démarre un bouquin je ne sais pas du
tout où il va se situer mais une feuille
blanche à la machine
et puis je me raconte l'histoire à la
ligne il sait pas dans une république
latino-américaine leur public de st
bravo oui capital bravissimo week et à
sa tête un dictateur qui s'appelle
chirac oh oui oh cugnaux avec chirac
n'ait pas pensé à chirac on n'avait pas
du tout si je l'avais appelé dur un
dossard et fait marrer personnes comme
il appelait chicago tout le monde rigole
et le secrétaire particulier à
particulier appel commun à la peine
qu'il est beau quand ils baissent et ça
j'aime autant vous voulez y ai dit que
moi et puis donc san antonio on peut
dire que membres à compter le début de
l'histoire
vous pouvez même raconté nous est pas
valable par l'histoire l'histoire
quelque chose qui m'emmène pas mené san
antonio je veux pas anticiper sur ce que
vous allez dire dans un instant je
suppose mais ça n'est valable que par
les mots c'est limoux qui m'amuse
cubaine une ce soir si vous ne racontez
pas nice où il irait pas oui bien sûr
mais l'histoire c'est une contrainte de
mon éditeur bon 12 contre 1 puisque
c'est ce qui a fait en définitive le
succès d'eads et des bouquins si je le
suis je m'étais fait plaisir à moi tout
seul sans passer égoïstement sans penser
aux autres afin qu'ils sont dans le
train et évidemment ça aurait pas eu le
petit succès que ça a rencontré
éternelle question qu'on se pose à
propos de vous certains disent oui san
antonio est lui au point par le groupe
public par l'époux jadis et
réactionnaire qui trouvent là de bandes
la violence de la sexualité et puis est
ce intellectuel très nombreux d'ailleurs
tellement violente et puis il ya des
intellectuels qu'ils disent n'est pas du
tout pas du tout san antonio derrière
goût rire se cache une moquerie
formidable et même parfois très triste
de notre monde sa sexualité de sa
violence alors qu'il faut il croire
écoutez je pense qu'ils ont raison de
ces intellectuels en raison parce que
derrière san antonio il ya un bonhomme
qui est moins et alors c'est un masque
merveilleuse parce que derrière ce
masque hilare je peux je peux tout dire
je peux tout faire je peux tout me
permettre la grammaire n'existe pas je
la manipule je fais ce que je veux de de
ddd situation des conjonctures je jongle
à m me pardonne tout qu'est-ce qu'il ya
un masque de carnaval
il nous fait rire du ferry mais j'ai
l'âge et la détermination la volonté
absolue de fait rire je crois que c'est
une espèce de charité que je dois mes
contemporains
parce que enfin lésés par on dit
toujours l'époque mahfal les époques
c'est à dire la vie et pas tellement
marrant toi disons le alors si on les
pisse pas si de temps à temps sans mène
pas promené si temps en temps sous pas
un peu de poil à gratter apprend que pas
pour rigoler où allons nous alors moi
c'est simplement du poil à gratter du
fluide glacial voudrait éternuer c'est
par exemple ce sont 80 il y a des
râteliers garni d'armes automatiques
contre le mur à ce que les deux
lance-roquettes sur pivot pour
apostropher des détenus au cap gris nez
ça vous prouve que je pensais
mes élucubrations et puis vous parlait
même de votre équité à la main avec
leurs marottes de lésiner sur le
papelard au fleuve et au fleuve noir il
ne me laisse pas ma chance
vous regrettez de ne laisse pas faire
des livres du groupe enfin on met berge
quand même dans les manuels gens
possèdent déjà une flopée sans blague je
suis dans livre et les grands
la rousse bordas casterman à pied à
cheval et en voiture dans d'autres
encore au super tu peux pas le bourg et
sur la fin dans la paralittérature c'est
bien d'ailleurs qu'au beau milieu de
tout des histoires rocambolesques que
vous racontez amusante mais parce que je
prends conscience vous voyez j'ai écrit
mon histoire bon quelquefois je suis
obligé de me chatouiller pour la faire
venir parce que ça vient pas comme ça on
a beau oui on a beau avoir du métier il
ya des matins où on aimerait autant
aller voyez à la pêche ou c'est pour ou
plutôt que de se mettre sa machine et
piteux de dire j'en étais où il était
dans la cave en train de se défendre
contre contre des contrôles à ben c'est
pas toujours marrant de faire ça alors
comme j'ai ma prise de conscience jeudi
si vous permettez mesdames je dis merde
je veux quand même mam n'est pas menée
je vais faire quelque chose pour moi et
faire quelque chose pour moi c'est
parler en mon nom pas parler au nom de
sa maintenu ou pas parler au nom de
l'auteur charge et d'amuser x milliers
de personnes mais du bonhomme qui écrit
ça et qui justement lève un petit coin
de son masque et sans menottes à mener
ce qu'on peut être vous avez un style
mais qu il met qu'un langage mec va
écouter si vous disiez frère je crois
que vous boirez pas tellement alors je
donne une définition du donné par marina
les dinos le stéréotype du langage viril
et l'appel ça où tout langage mais
qu'implique lusage de l'argot et de la
langue verte c'est vous la pratique du
jeu de mots c'est vous et singulièrement
du jeu de mot à caractère sexuel sous le
coup d'injure on s'approche de la sécu
ça me cabu la peluche et plus étendue
vous êtes larrinaga galop fenech d'air
et vraiment on se remet encierros
nautique de ce que vous appelez le
langage mec
oui certainement oui c'est un peu le
stéréotype victimes
et là vous en prenez à lui vous n'avez
pas d'après l'ademe et beaucoup de
l'engagement n'ont pas dit non non non
pas du tout c'est pas que je n'aime pas
la langue
mais globalement je le définis et je
donne l'image du stéréotype de joueurs
tels que vous avez lu ici je le pose un
autre stéréotype et c'est plutôt celui
ci que je remets en cause le stéréotype
du langage femme qui nous enferme dans
une espèce de deux langages bobl langage
fab langage bébêtes je l'apprécié les on
arrive à sortir je l' ai vu tout de
suite dans son regard
j'ai certes renaître à la première
vision
ceux qui sont pour et ceux qui sont
tombés j'ai un beau parterre de pour je
dois dire ici je pense - du compte quand
j'arrive je le vois marina et madame y
avait le masque pas celui dont je
parlais tout à l'heure
non là c'était l'autre ne vais pas
annoncer sa présidence et m cécile et je
trouve que la façon dont une crise rues
d'agde a effectivement sexiste mais il
joue avec donc je vais pas jouer le jeu
lui dire vous êtes sexistes parce qu'il
aura beau jeu de dire oui mais je fais
exprès ça m'amuse donc de citations je
le ferai pas sans reproche il écrit
comme ça c'est puis certaines règles
d'un certain jeu qu'il manie très bien
mon police beernem et me ricardo vous
aimez vivre bien grand personnage
chemise les bérurier pourrait vraiment
être revendiquée par le préfet me dit
oui à l'initiative est la somme tout le
monde
c'est un personnage plaisir
extraordinaire
bonjour moi je suis pour que vision tout
nous sommes toutes des berneries
rubrique enfin vous défilent dans la rue
or hier les verts c'est un personnage
étonnant d'ailleurs des amis qui ont
appelé leur maison la berruyère il
oui je suppose il a aussi passé des
choses si j'aime bien mais quand
j'entends free rider dire que madame
attention vous allez dire je vais vous
dire un gros mot dans la jme dis si
j'arrivais avec une bouteille de rouge
dans ma poche et s'il se répéter les
bons vieux ça serait le personnage plus
vrai que nature et je préfère m'excuser
au préalable que pour dire merde je
trouve que quelques là et l'humour ça
pour moi je me refuse à dire beaucoup
palm mais l'excusé préalable et
inattendue je crois qu'on est tous les
trois la même élection directement en
fait pourquoi prendre des gants que vous
dites mais nous sommes pas des gants par
dérision
je me veux pas vous je me moque de lui
merde c'est pas pareil ça n'a absolument
rien à voir mais ce genre à ne jamais
débuter son métier si vous en étiez à
adé à démerder à des taux si je toujours
si j'osais demander pardon
ça serait dommage c'est donc une
démission de sa puissance ou alors
nicole et ce n'est rien
j'admirais cardo si vous avez oui mais
voyez pardon je n'en mets je jure que je
ne dis plus rien je vais lire
remplacez merde par kate beckett c'est
quand même assez faiblard vous pas comme
ça qu'on bat sa femme
non non mais écoutez je sais que vous
avez fait quelque chose de très
chouettes
j'anticipe peut-être elles ont fait un
bouquet très bon tout le monde m'en
parle bien de sortie j'ai déjà des tas
bécaud je n'ai pas encore lu parce que
je suis une vieille feignasses et ce
avec deux jours je lai mais je vous jure
que votre bouquin a déjà de très très
très bon et fou hein alors pas d'al ahly
remplacer maire d'arqués kate s'est
passé coustous sa quéquette ces mines a
encore enflammé c'est parti à sortir
mais qu'on le dise aiglons oui
génération de remplacer comparé ces
couillons
pourquoi
[Musique]